certain kinds of random variables keep
coming up so let's look at two basic
examples now namely uniform random
variables and binomial random variables
let's begin with uniform because we've
seen those already so a uniform random
variable means that all the values that
it takes it takes with equal probability
so the threshold variable Z took all the
values from 0 to 6 inclusive each with
probability 1 7 so it was a basic
example of a uniform variable and other
examples that come up if D is the
outcome of a fair die dizer six-sided
dice or six-sided so the probability
that it comes up 1 or 2 or 6 is 1/6 each
another game is the four-digit lottery
number where it's supposed to be the
case that the four digits are each
chosen at random which means that the
possibilities range from four zeros up
through four nines for 10,000 numbers
and they're supposed to be all equally
likely so the probability that the
lottery winds up with 0 0 is the same as
that it ends up with 1 is the same that
it ends up with four 9s it's one 10,000
so that's another uniform random
variable let's prove a little lemma that
will be of use later it's just some
practice with uniformity suppose that I
have R 1 R 2 R 3 R 3 random variables
they're mutually independent and are one
of them is an R 1 is uniform I don't
really care about the other two I do
care
technically that they are only taking
the values they only take values that
are one can take as well so I haven't
sent out on the slide but that's what
we're assuming and then I claim is that
each of the pairs the the probability
that R 1 equals R 2 is independent of
the event that R 1 is equal R 2 is
independent of the event that R 2 is
equal to e 3 which is independent of the
event that R 1 is equal to R 3 now these
events overlap there's an R 1 here
there's an art
and on our 1 there and there's an art to
here and an art to there so even though
the R 1 R 2 R 3 are mutually independent
it's not completely clear in fact it
isn't really clear that these events are
mutually independent but in fact they're
not mutually independent in fact they're
pairwise independent they're obviously
not three-way independent that is
mutually independent because if I know
that R 1 is equal to R 2 and I know that
R 2 is equal to R 3 it follows that R 1
is equal to R 3 so given these two the
probability of this changes dramatically
to be just a certainty so this is a
useful lemma which is that if I have the
three variables ne and I look at the
three possible pairs that moverá values
that might be equal on that whether any
two of them are equal is independent of
each other now let me give a hand waving
argument there's a rigger a more
rigorous argument based on total
probability that appears as a problem in
the text but the intuitive idea is let's
look at the case that R 1 is the uniform
variable and R 1 is independent of R 2
and R 3 so certainly that implies that R
1 is independent of the event that R 2
is equal to R 3 because R 1 is in
mutually independent both R 1 and R 2
doesn't matter what they do so it's
independent of this event that R 2 is
equal to R 3 now because arm 1 is
uniform
it has probability P of equaling what
every possible value that it can take
and since R 2 and R 3 only take a value
that r1 could take the probability that
R 1 hits the value that R 2 and R 3
happens to have is still people that's
the informal argument so in other words
the claim is that the probability that R
1 is equal to R 2 given that R 2 is
equal to R 3 is simply the probability
that R 1 happens to hit R to whatever
values R 2 has this equation says that R
1 equals R 2 is independent of R 2 R 3
and in fact in both cases it's the same
probability that R 1 is a
to any given value the probability of
that are being uniform has it equal in
each of its possible values you can
think about that see if it's persuasive
it's actually a it's an okay argument
but I was bothered by it I found then it
took me I wasn't happy with it until I
sat down and really worked it out
formally to justify this somewhat hand
wavy proof of the lemma all right let's
turn from uniform random variables to
binomial random variables they're
probably the most important single
example of random variable that comes up
comes up all the time so the simplest
definition of a binomial random variable
is the one that you get by flipping n
mutually independent coins or
alternative it no they they have an
order so you can tell them apart or
again you could say that you flip on one
coin n times but each of the flips is
independent of all the others now
there's two parameters here an N and a P
because we don't assume that the flips
are fair so there's uh one parameter is
how many flips there are the other
parameter is the probability of a head
which might be biased that heads are
more likely or less likely than tails
the fair case would be when P was 1/2 so
for example if n is 5 and P is 2/3
what's the probability that we
consecutively flip head head tail tail
head well because they're independent
the probability of this is simply the
product of the probability that I flip a
head on the first toss which is
probability of H which is P probability
of H on the second toss probability of T
on the third T on the fourth T on the
fifth so I can replace each of those by
2/3 is the probability of a head 2/3 1/3
2/3 my 1 minus 2/3 probability of a tail
1/3 2/3 and I discover that the
probability of H HT th is 2/3 cubed and
1/3 squared or abstracting the
probability of a sequence of n tosses in
which there are a heads
and the rest retails n - I tails is
simply the probability of an of a head
raised to the I power times the
probability of a tail namely 1 minus P
raised to the n - - I've power given any
particular sequence of HS and TS of
length n this is the probability that's
assigned to that sequence so all
sequences with the same number of HS
have the same probability
but of course with different numbers of
H's they have different probabilities
well what's the probability that you
actually toss a heads and n - I tails in
the end tosses that's going to be equal
to the number of possible sequences that
have this property of I heads and n
minus I tails well the number of such
sequences is simply choose the I places
for the n heads out of for the other
choose the I places for the heads out of
the n tosses so it's going to be n
choose I so we've just figured out that
the probability of tossing I heads and n
minus four five tails is simply n choose
I times P to the I 1 minus P to the N
minus I in short the probability that
the number of heads is I is equal to
this number and this is the probability
that's associated with whether the
binomial variable with parameters N and
P is equal to I is n choose IP to the I
1 minus P to the N minus I this is
pretty basic formula if you can't
memorize it then make sure it's written
on any crib sheet you take to an exam so
the probability density function it
abstracts out some properties of random
variables basically it just tells you
what's the probability that the random
variable takes a given value for every
possible value so the probability
density function um
piece of PDF of R is a function on the
real values and it tells you for each a
what's the probability that R is equal
to a so for e so what we've just said is
that the probability density function of
the binomial random variable per
characterized by parameters n in P at I
is n choose I P to the I 1 - P
the n- i were we're assuming that I is
between as an integer from zero to end
if I look at the probability density
function for a uniform variable then
it's constant the probability density
function on any possible value V that
the that the uniform variable can take
is the same this implies for V in the
range of U so in fact you can say
exactly what it is it's simply 1 over
the size of the range of u if u is
uniform a closely related function that
describes a lot about the behavior of a
random variable is the cumulative
distribution function it's simply the
probability that R is less than or equal
to a so it's a function on the real
numbers from reels to reels of the where
PDF R of a CDF R of a is the probability
that R is less than or equal to a
clearly given the PDF you can define the
you can get the CDF and given the CDF
you can get the PDF but it's convenient
to have both around now the key
observation about these is that once
we've abstracted out to the PDF and the
CDF we don't have to think about the
sample space anymore they do not depend
on the sample space well they're telling
you is the probability that the random
variable takes a given value which is in
some ways the most important data about
a random variable you need to fall back
on something more general than the PDF
where the CDF when you are start having
dependent random variables and you need
to know how the probability that R takes
a value changes given that s has some
property or take some other value but if
you're just looking at the random
variable alone essentially everything
you need to know about it is given by
its by its density or distribution
functions and you don't have to worry
about the sample space and this has the
advantage that both the uniform
distributions and binomial distributions
come up
and it means that all of these different
random variables based on different
sample spaces are gonna share a whole
lot of properties everything that I
derive based on what the PDF is is going
to apply to all of them that's why this
abstraction of a random variable in
terms of a probability density function
is so valuable and key but remember the
definition of a random variable is not
that it is a probability density
function rather it's a function from the
sample space to values